I do this pose called doll eye I can
close one eye at a time and still like
maintain all function Katy Perry's got
one eye shut but she's still
let's rewind the singer's unexpected
party trick first went viral back in
October when she demonstrated it during
her Las Vegas residency show when you
see a new 2023 play date I play a doll
I'm sitting on a larger than life props
because everything in the show is
Larger than Life fast forward to March
and Katie's explaining her hidden talent
to Vogue I've sat in a hair and makeup
chair for 15 years if they're putting
eyeshadow on this eye and someone's
putting my hair up into a French twist I
want to give notes in real time yeah she
can fully do it on command
[Music]
and seems the girl can't help herself it
feels like Destiny check out Katie
backstage at the Broadway play and
Juliet giving actor Matt Rafi a crash
course but really Katie's got all kinds
of Tricks Up firstly she's a master at
eating meatballs
and this needs no explanation come to us
on this side
oh oh
god oh
it's a tree frog Jokes Aside Katie's
also got a sensitive side you deserve a
second chance yeah after a single mom's
audition didn't go as planned Katie's
encouragement helped her regain her
confidence I'm excited to see you bloom
into your fullest potential
it's a yes
we support them we nurture them we give
them constructive criticism and they're
really entering into a a university as
Lionel likes to put a a crash course a
fast pace crash course of the music
industry
[Music]